[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So, if any of you out there
would like to ask questions--
STEVEN BAZYL: Hi, everyone.
We're back for another Google
Developers Live, talking about
Google Drive.
And today we're going
to do an app review
on ASTRO File Manager.
I'm Steven Bazyl and--
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: I'm
Alain Vongsouvanh.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah, so
this is a great app.
This is one of the first
mobile applications to
actually launch on Drive.
It's a file manager.
It's been around for a while.
They have, like I say, a lot
of users, tens of millions,
and just recently, maybe about
a week or two ago,
launched Version 4.
Now, it's a complete redesign
of the application and
includes things-- and not just
a redesign for the ICS and
Jelly Bean styles, --but also
support for cloud services,
including Google Drive
and Dropbox.
We'll take a look at that
in just a moment.
I do have to get here.
I do want to show you the Play
Store entry for this
application here.
And you can actually
just see some of--
these are the older screenshots
for the
application.
I'll just launch
a few of these.
It was a good app.
Again, very popular, but I just
want to give you a sense
for what the old style of the
application is before we jump
into the new one.
So let's actually go
switch over here.
We have it up.
I do have to apologize.
We are in landscape mode.
This app does look a little
bit better in portrait.
So if you do have a Jelly Bean
device, and you want to try it
out and explore it,
you could do that.
But this is the landing page
for the application.
A few features I want to point
out before we dive into the
drive-specific functionality
and how they did this--
and we'll talk a little bit more
about Android development
for Drive as we go
through this.
But in addition to having some
very high-level functionality
here for accessing your files
organized by type so you can
see documents, music, pictures,
videos, my files,
these are all just built-in
searches that will find all
the relevant files for you.
And the cool thing is it will
actually do this across all
your different sources, whether
it's an SD card,
Google Drive, Dropbox, or any
other network location that it
happens to work with.
It does also have some built-in
tools that make it a
little bit more powerful than
just a file manager.
You can see card usage in terms
of utilization, what
directories and files are taking
up the most space, a
Task Killer.
Not something that you need on
newer versions of Android so
much, but they're for people who
do want to go in and just
force-kill different things,
and, of course, an Application
Manager as well.
And if you swipe in the other
direction, we can see all the
different locations.
We have our local storage.
We can access network locations
over Wi-Fi, Drive
Dropbox, and again, these
built-in searches here.
So, pretty useful.
And I'm just going to click on
Music here, just to get the
basic idea of what
this looks like.
You can see here it's finding
different audio clips that are
on my device.
We can actually change this
into a different view.
Thumbnails for music--
not very useful.
Let's go back to here,
and how about
we'll do pictures instead.
So Pictures is something
that works much
better in grid view.
You can see the default
thumbnails here, but these
will fill in as it goes through
and scans those files.
So most of these are actually
on my local device here.
We can go over and look
at Google Drive
functionality directly.
So I'm going to go, and I
actually have this hooked up
to my Gmail account.
And we can see here, it's
going to start to load.
It is a little slower
than accessing
an SD card, of course.
That's to be expected.
But you can see here, it's
actually already started to
load in the content.
We have thumbnails for
different images.
These are little characters I
made for a barbecue we're
having, PDF files, ZIP
files, images.
Basically these are using-- you
can even see here for the
PDFs, we're actually getting the
thumbnail images as well.
And these are basically images
that are generated
by the drive API.
And wall thumbnails, many of
these images and documents as
possible, and they're just
taking advantage of that to
give a really nice presentation
here.
Using the app is--
let's go find a nice
little Google duck.
I think I have in here a
nice Drive demo folder.
Let's see if I can
get to it here.
And we should have
some ducks that--
let's try this one here.
So you could open that file.
And I think this is
a Google Doc.
Or maybe it's not.
How about My Resume?
We'll use that as one.
We may be running into a little
technical glitch here.
One thing I do have to
warn you, this is a--
oh, this wasn't a Google
Doc either.
It was actually just
a Word doc.
So I actually just launched
the built-in
document viewer for this.
I can go back.
Basically what I did want to
find was a Google document.
Basically what this will do-- in
the case of we know whether
it's a Google Doc or
a spreadsheet or a
presentation--
is actually launch that with the
built-in Google Drive app,
so very useful.
And Alain, you had done a
presentation on integrating
Android apps with Google
Drive back at I/O.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
That's correct.
STEVEN BAZYL: I know we've been
a little bit slow to get
out one of the services that
people have been waiting for,
the Google Play Services.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Still
not launched yet.
So Google Play Services has been
announced at Google I/O
and hopefully should be
available shortly.
It's a new set of services that
will be coming to Android
devices starting from Froyo.
And it will provide a set of
APIs that will make it easier
for developers to authorize web
application to get access
to some Google APIs, such
as Google Drive.
So, right now, the only way to
get an access token-- well,
there are two ways.
The main one is using
Account Manager.
But the token you get back is
not linked to any API project.
So, because of that, the Drive
API has no way to know which
API project is requesting
access to which files.
And the Drive API introduced
a new set of permissions.
Like an app can only request
access to files that it has
access to or the user opened
with these applications.
And because the Account Manager
doesn't let Google
Drive know which API project is
requesting access, the API
won't work when requesting and
an access token with the
Account Manager.
So I believe what ASTRO is
currently doing is using the
old API, which is called the
Documents List API, I
guess Version 3.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah.
I believe so as well.
And it does have some
disadvantages for mobile devices.
So some of the features, like
partial retrievals so you can
be selective in terms of the
fields that you download, is
not available in that API.
But it is in the Drive API.
Actually, it's really important
for mobile apps in
terms of minimizing bandwidth
usage, so taking advantage of
things like gzip compression,
selective
retrieval of fields--
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
JSON metadata.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah, exactly.
The JSON is just a lot more
compact to begin with.
I'm really anxious to get them
onto the new API once those
Play Services are released.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
Yes, me, too.
STEVEN BAZYL: But they
actually did
a really good job.
The nice thing is that
the APIs are
functionally very similar.
You have the same type of
metadata, access to the same
thumbnails, downloading files
is pretty much the same,
regardless of which API
you use to actually
search for the content.
So it shouldn't be that
difficult of a
change for them to make.
And again, something we're
really hoping to see once
those services are
fully available.
A couple little features in
the app I want to show.
Let's do--
so we can do long presses
on different things
here to bring up--
we can actually Copy
files, Move, Trash.
We can actually send these off
to other applications.
And this is just using the
regular Android intent.
We can actually send a Drive
file to Google Drive.
I'm not sure what
that would do.
But they also have properties.
So you can see here the name,
path to the file, MIME types,
and everything.
So this is pretty useful.
There are some things
that might be
useful for them to add.
So one of the things that's
missing in here is you really
can't take advantage of Drive's
sharing features.
So we have in the API the
ability to manage the ACL,
share the file with
users or groups.
That is not something that
they've have exposed yet
through their UI, but it is
available in the native Drive
client for Android.
I'm a little torn, personally,
as to whether or not I would
recommend them actually
recreating that feature.
It is a lot of work to build
an ACL dialogue and pull in
Google contacts and the circles
from Plus, and all
those different sources
of information about
who to share with.
One thing that'll be interesting
is, for example,
for web application, we have
a sharing dialogue that's
embeddable with JavaScript.
I think it would actually be
kind of cool if we could do
something similar for
mobile applications.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes, it's
like providing intent from the
Drive app to start the sharing
dialogue for a specific file.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah, it seems
like that would be a really
great feature.
I know when you did your
presentation, you talked a lot
about building viewers and
editors for Android.
And it seems like that would
be something to have that
share dialogue embedded in that
mobile application, that
native application as you're
working on the file and as
you're thinking about who
to collaborate with.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
Yes, I agree.
So many of you may not know, but
the Drive app on Android
has an open weave integration,
the same open weave flow we
have on Google Drive Web UI.
So you can click on a file, and
if Drive doesn't know how
to open, it will prompt the user
with a dialogue showing
applications but can respond
to this intent.
And this works the same way
as the Drive Web UI.
So it will authorize the app to
get access to the file and
then open the app with either
the file ID, if they're
integrated with the intent,
or the content
directly as a blob.
As Steve mentioned, it would be
nice for the Drive app to
also provide intent to be able
to share files from another
application, let another
application start the sharing
process for a specific file.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah, definitely
something that would be a
great feature.
And I think we'll have to file
a feature request on our side
to see that in there.
Overall, I'm really happy
with this application.
I mean, file managers are kind
of one of those things where--
it's not something you
use every day.
But since I've had ASTROs, since
I've been working with
these guys, I do find more and
more occasions to use them.
They're particularly great when
using applications that
download files.
I have files in my download
folder and my SD card.
I want to move those
into Drive.
I've actually used that on a
number of occasions already.
A lot of times when I uninstall
applications, they
leave behind files.
It's a great way to go back
and clean them up.
So it's not an everyday utility,
but it's really,
really well done.
I love the new version
of this application.
And as mentioned earlier, it is
right now only available on
devices with Jelly Bean.
And I do know they're planning
on rolling out
ICS in the near future.
It is really new.
There still are some
kinks in there.
But I know the guys
working on this.
They're hard at work making
this really just a really
awesome app.
And there's not a lot of
features that I think are
missing other than things like
the drive sharing and other
features like that.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Do
you know if they use
the revisions feature?
Like can you get access to
another revision of a file?
STEVEN BAZYL: That's a
really good question.
And I don't think so.
Let's actually take a look
at this one here.
So I know they have some Google
Drive functionality.
These are your shortcuts.
On Properties, it does
not look like it.
And if it is there, it's
not necessarily
obvious how to get to.
But yeah, that's actually
another really good
suggestion, is accessing
revisions.
That would be something that's
very Drive specific, though.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
That's correct.
STEVEN BAZYL: Although
Dropbox actually has
revisions as well.
So for the file systems that
have it, that would actually
be a really, really cool
feature to add.
Yeah, it's a really, really
well-done app.
And again, one of the first
mobile apps that's really--
I mean, it's super deeply
integrated with Drive.
In a lot of cases, you could use
this in lieu of the actual
native Drive app.
If you happen to work on local
file system and cloud file
systems together, it gives you
a nice, unified interface for
doing that.
I'm trying to think.
Any other suggestions you think
would be really useful
or features?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Well, I'm
thinking when the Google Play
Services launch, it will
be nice for them to
migrate to a Drive API.
And I believe it will make
things a lot easier for them
for the long run.
Like dealing with JSON metadata
instead of XML, using
the lightweight client libraries
we do provide for
Java and Android, a lot of
this would make a lot of
things a lot more easier
for them and for
developers in general.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah,
definitely.
And again, for the performance
improvements of just having a
lot smaller payloads is really
important for mobile devices.
So I think a lot of developers
are looking forward to having
the Play Services out there.
I know there is a ton of other
mobile developers we've been
chatting to about Drive,
and they're
anxious to get started.
So, I think that's all
we have for this.
Again, you can check out the
app, if you have a device with
Jelly Bean on it.
You can just download it
from the Play Store.
Give it a try with Drive
and Dropbox and just
stuff on your SD card.
And if you like the app, give it
a review in the Play Store.
I think it's really solid and
really enjoyed working with
these guys to make
it a great app.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Great.
STEVEN BAZYL: All right.
We will be back on Tuesday,
is that right?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: On Monday.
STEVEN BAZYL: Monday.
Monday OK.
So, yeah.
Be back Monday.
I don't know what the topic is,
but you can check out the
schedule on the Developers Live
site, and we'll make sure
that's updated for
Monday's topic.
OK, thanks.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
[MUSIC PLAYING]